[Applause]
so uh I watch a lot of interracial porn
yeah not for the sex I just want to see
a black man interview a white woman for
a job in some points the black dudes
have better jobs and never seen black
dudes have in real life there just be
like lawyers business owners cello
instructors I've never seen a black
challenge Chuck actually only know two
black people with job security my mom a
city worker for 30 years and Kenan
Thompson one thing I'm looking forward
to in the news is uh Harriet Tubman
being on the $20 bill I think that's
dope especially for rap music because
now make it rain would be referred to as
Emancipation precipitation I love that
joke more than I love my girlfriend
we're living in the time now where
people argue on behalf of black people
about things black people aren't even
upset about I heard this one white lady
on line she was like I'm upset and
outraged by the lack of diversity in Tim
Burton movies
and I know for a fact that black people
don't care about being in timber it's
not like I woke up this morning like you
know what the most difficult thing about
being a black man in America
I'm unrepresented in Edwardson I went I
went to a boarding school or something I
did I remember I was like one three
black kids in that school even though
it's a predominately black neighborhood
it was weird it was kind of like going
to a Kendrick Lamar a Kanye West concert
because like this should have been black
people there but there weren't I
remember I had this one roommate named
Prescott yeah and recently I found out
he died in a boating incident which is
sad but I also think if your name is
Prescott that's how you should die white
kids and the black kids we really get
along but the one thing we both had in
common that we both hated was the
Ethiopian exchange student his name was
Ricky Jay he was 14 and 12th grade and
you'd already written several books you
thought he was better than us because he
was better than us we were talking about
raising me like I'll see black people
I'll see white people all I see is
stupid people he's a dictator now I
think I think it's funny how some people
don't believe in depression but believe
in Jesus
[Laughter]
Jesus was depressed like he watched
people's feet using his hair in tears he
got a friend who wash people's feet
using his hand tears he'd be like at
least I'm doing better than Jesus
also his description in the Bible that
just says jesus wept jesus wept
that means somebody saw him crying it
was like yep that's what he's doing
try to help him at all just want me to
Bible just a lot of bad friends read the
Bible that verse was like jesus wept and
then I went and asked him if he was all
right and he said it's not one big thing
just a lot little small we need that
especially today we are we are living in
a weird political time right now I know
cuz I'm on Facebook a lot of people
getting political arguments on Facebook
calling Facebook drama if Facebook is
drama for people who've never been in a
fist fight gone think Facebook is drama
cuz I've been in a fist fight I come
from the projects the only time I've
seen words hurt someone is when I saw a
girl get hit with a belt buckle that
said Denise
people like oh you call me a lips are
there hurts my feelings I'm like you
must not know Denise
[Applause]
you